[Music]
Mark Wahlberg is also dealing with his
own daddy issues we'll get to that in a
second but first we talked about his new
movie mile 22 which Mark got into the
best shape of his life for you ramped up
on a different level than most human
beings what does that mean all the fun
stuff that's not good for you gets
locked out and shut down the beast mode
mark trained for five months and legit
got an 8 pack all to play an elite
American intelligence officer in mile 22
part of his top secret team Ronda Rousey
who we got to surprise mark with his
favorite cheap meal how was it
physically was it easy for you because I
mean you've gotten a few scrapes before
so uh well I kept trying to set my hair
on fire that was the only thing like
physically everything was fine except
for Pete wanted to shave my head of any
wanna shave her head yeah and I was like
I'm a Pantene girl you can't shave my
head so he was like okay I'm just going
to stick you in a house where there's
flamethrowers shooting at you one but
it's me fine so yeah he tried to burn my
hair up I put a lot of flame retardant
in except for one day I did almost burn
all my hair off but he actually mark
shouted at me the boot
he saved my hair you can be [ __ ] okay no
I mean you shave it heads is a good
thing for you thank you I was gonna say
no don't disrespect shave head
you also don't disrespect mark unless
you're one of his four kids it turns out
they don't like having a famous dad you
have never see dad you ruin everything
my son you was just going to summer
school and he's like dad wait in the car
I'm like and dropping you off at your
first day on a new campus you don't even
know where you're going like now mom was
there but well stay 30 feet behind us
then all of a sudden I'm the weird guy
who's just wandering by myself with my
bowl
but yeah I'm still gonna be there
[Music]